today we guess within mystery box
[Music]
don't like to stick my hands in anything
if it's not a bag of hot cheetos I'm
scared of squishing tiny things I'm
looking at this table whatever then the
box is alive I hope it's like a cute
little bird in the box
I hope anything that's not alive we have
to feel in the box no no no no oh hello
there view this can't bite us bye do I
need to be careful it's a frog it's like
a wet oh did you pout is it a rod shake
is that pee it's wet paper towel it's a
wet cloth
oh are you are you kidding no this is
unsettling wait I totally heard
something one two three
grab it Hedgehog porcupine thing is it
think it's a lizard is it a toilet brush
it just sounds like a snake that was too
much emotional stress
three hours of scary dark suspense or
yeah what what I feel they heard
something I'm gonna do it I can't tell
what I'm hearing in my head and what I'm
Jerry I enjoy I've never seen anyone as
scared as Umbro have concluded from this
experience definitely freaked myself out
more than anything
are there puppies coveting or not the
music was a nice touch it definitely
felt like you're entering like a haunted
house you see this this is me to the
PAC's
turns out I'm very uncomfortable when
you take away any form of my bodily
control this is a good lesson to just go
for it and not second-guess yourself so
here's the thing we were not promised
puppies but we assumed puppies and we
stand by that assumption
[Music]